yeah they're facing spencer howard
spence coming into this ball game a wing
two
an era of 5.11 last outing win three
innings
against the yankees one hit two
strikeouts
and a fastball and a strike three call
right at the bottom of the zone he's not
happy but that's a really good pitch
96 miles an hour one two three go the
nets
a ground out a fly out and a strikeout
spencer howard his first strikeout of
the night
we'll head to the bottom of the first
hit against the nationals nothing of the
phillies coming up
joe ross against philadelphia seven
games five starts
two and one with a two six five
last start fourth of july against the
dodgers took the to 5-1 loss
three runs on seven hits over six and
two thirds season high 11 strikeouts
little q shot it was foul then it went
fair
and josh bell first he took his time
how about jt he saw he saw that he had a
chance
they may look at it but bill welke was
right on it
yeah and josh bell didn't even turn
around to say look at it
he knew he messed up all you got to do
tagging
on a pitch up 95 blowton right by him
we're talking about joe ross his
increased velocity
target in again ross gets it in there
and he gets the fly ball
not deep who takes charge soda 1
3rd coming in and
safe is the call
[Music]
[Applause]
tris barrera immediately to his third
base dugout
and the nats will surely take a look and
thank goodness juan soto took charge
here because nobody was there you go
he's out that's a double play and the
setting's over
and it's a double play it'll go 9-2
thanks to juan soto at the end of june
the phillies sent spencer down to
aaa to try to stretch him out
to go deeper into games he went five
innings his first start in the minors
in a swing and a miss threw him a change
up and he picked up his second strikeout
six up six down for howard
upstairs unreachable joe ross second
strikeout two down
and here's the two two i wouldn't never
know it can happen
that's in there top of the zone a couple
of guys with good command
to start this one
it's that one sharply on one hop dini's
got it flips to second for one segura to
first in time
two thirds of the way through your plan
john
a six four three double play what that
was a heck of a turn by dede and segura
man i
you know well we know saguaro has a
great arm but watch the feed though
by dede once he got this ball i mean
that is just a perfect throw for segura
to turn a double play on a guy who can
run in robles
mccutcheon pulls it harrison looking the
short way and that's it
two stranded by the phillies they've
left four to the middle innings we go
lost looking good scoreless josh bell
looking for the two out rbi knock
that ball was sitting up and now it's
flying up
did he get it at the very top of the
wall
it stays in play scoring is escobar
bell heading for third rbi number 47
for josh bell another guy who puts the
bat on the ball more often than not
harrison pulls it that's a base hit to
make it two nothing
[Applause]
and now a little slip by mccutchen
and josh harrison heading to third high
stepping it in there
back-to-back triples how often do you
see that by two guys named josh come on
and that ball is ripped for a base hit
the nats are five for six this inning
and it's three nothing
another two out knock in another run
biting that
some skin off there i don't know if he
has a blister i've never seen the
manager the pitching coach and the
trainer go out and that's it
that's it all right so spencer is done
after three and two thirds
and the phillies will have to go to the
bullpen early
that ball is ripped to right parra
coming around harper's throw way off
line
the gnats lead four nothing and they're
seven
for eight in the city
sharply at a diving stop by the reyes
he'll flip it over to first it doesn't
matter he's out at third
it's a liner that's caught by the reyes
tell you what that's one of the
advantages about having a short third
baseman tommy he didn't have far to go
to get that one
so they had brad miller on deck and now
they switched to mickey moniak the
number one overall draft pick by the
phillies
five years ago and a pitch at 93
with the wave movement at the end joe
ross
strikeout number four
right side escobar to his left
out of the inning is joe ross so he gets
through five
hasn't given up a hit to a non-pitcher
since the second batter of the game for
nothing next
[Applause]
swag in a miss he came all the way back
he was down 3-0 and he struck out
para and now two outs in the sixth
is that 101 101 johnny well that'll get
you a ticket
line drive out to center field
o'doodle's coming on makes the catch
the innings over no runs there were no
hits there were three walks though
nationals leave them loaded all right
rhys hoskins is due up
he's fifth in the league in doubles and
an extra base hits
and one here would be a doozy fly ball
out to left forget about it it's a
one-run game
reece hoskins a three-run home run
and a little life back here in the old
ballpark
it's a 4-3 ball game
[Applause]
that's a ball because he didn't stop
that's what the umpires are saying
so that'll put soto up into second base
now they're gonna walk bell to face josh
harrison
take a look at the the the ball you're
supposed to
stop for at least one second one one
thousand
line drive caught by the reyes over at
third
he gets the tag out for the fourth out
of the inning
and hector bends just a little bit
and doesn't break so they're loaded with
one out for bell
breaking ball chopped very high and
everybody is safe the nets lead five to
three
some fortunate things going on on the
infield during this inning
first and third one out and mccutcheon's
coming up the tying run is over at first
out to right field soto's going back
this game is
over andrew mccutchen has just walked
it off for the fills an office and field
three
run home run six
five oh what a celebration around home
plates